stéphane vite offs qui bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rmc france alors
nous sommes donc cinq ans jour pour jour
après la mort de fidel castro que
reste-t-il aujourd'hui son héritage est
ce qu'il va être honoré aujourd'hui par
les cubains
il sera certainement honoré par les
institutions ou gouvernement cubain bien
sûr il ya une forme de nostalgie comme
le dit votre reportage parce qu'il était
quand même associé bien sûr à comme
figure avec un légende associé à la
révolution de 1909 aussi parce que il a
eu ce rôle déteint sur la scène
internationale qu'il voces ce reportage
en particulier le fait qu'il ait tenu
tête à à 11 président nord-américain et
puis surtout qu'il apparaissait aussi
comme un protecteur pour beaucoup de
cubains notamment dans les crises et en
particulier après la disparition union
soviétique et comme il ya une sorte de
parallélisme entre la crise économique
actuelle économiques et financières très
difficiles nous coupons établi un
parallélisme entre eux la période
spéciale en temps de paix qui a suivi la
disparition l'union soviétique où il a
joué un rôle dans les années 92 93 94
parce qu'effectivement il a vu une
divinité une dimension d'un aspect un
peu visionnaire dans dans les dents dans
l'analyse de la crise mais en
particulier il apparaissait comme au
fond l'homme qui pouvait
assurer une forme de
grandir de protection de la population
et y est une population aussi de plus en
plus âgées ce qui compte du sien
problème le défi démocratie dans l'île
vous avez vous l'avez d un fidel castro
qui a été qui a tenu tête à une
multitude de président américain il ya
eu un dégel avec barack obama et puis un
renforcement des sanctions sous donald
trump qu'en est il aujourd'hui avec joe
byden quel type de relation y at-il avec
les dirigeants de lille
alors il ya eu effectivement un
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques sous obama
mais qui n'a pu être
poursuivis parce qu'il manquait au fond
une dimension c'est la normalisation des
relations entre les deux pays en
particulier
deux conditions étaient requises d'une
part la levée de l'embargo
dans l'élite depuis 1962 qui pénalise
l'économie du pays depuis 1962 et puis
là le retrait de la base de guantanamo
de communes comme appartenant aux états
unis en d'autres termes les relations
avec by dell
ont été
gelée ici je puis dire et sont toujours
gelé parce que la politique train qui a
été mise en place
caractérisé par le renforcement de
l'embargo
à l'embargo sont rajoutés 240 mesures
particulièrement pénalisant pour lille
et en particulier le non accès en grande
partie la limitation ce qu'on appelle
des transferts de la diaspora kebano
américaine qui constituent la deuxième
source de devises du pays et ça pénalise
considérablement beaucoup de familles
cubaines cet aspect là a été
terriblement
c'est quelque chose qui apparaît
évidemment au quotidien s'ajoute aussi
le fait que les restrictions des
touristes américains d'orly ont été
considérablement diminué si vous
rajoutez la crise de l'aco vider le fait
que le pdt coupe est fermée à tous les
touristes étrangers
explique évidemment les tensions
économiques et sociales dans le pays
deux chiffres en 2010 9 cuba recevait
qu'un million de touristes cette année
ce sera au mieux trois cent mille la fin
d'année et donc c'est une aussi une
deuxième source de la visite très
importante dans l'île alors john avait
avait promis pendant sa campagne
de parler de ce dossier de cuba or pour
l'instant il n'en est rien
il en est rien pour des raisons de
politique intérieure américaine c'est
vrai que brydon a besoin de consolider
sa majorité démocrate au congrès qui est
encore très fragile il tant qu
effectivement il ya cette déchéance les
élections à mi-mandat l'année prochaine
aux etats unis baden ne prendra aucune
initiative de politique intérieure vous
savez que tous les présidents nord
américains républicains et démocrates
ont besoin de tous les lobbys et ce
lobby kebano américain est extrêmement
influent nous en r non seulement en
termes de 2,2 je dirais de d'appui
financier mais surtout parce que il ya
un certain nombre de personnalités clefs
aux états unis qui
sont en général des cubano-américains
bloc en quelque sorte toutes formes
d'évolution politique
intérieure auprès de politique
extérieure de l'administration
américaine vis-à-vis t l'exception
ç'avait été obama parce qu'il avait été
réélu avec une très large majorité
démocrate son
deuxième mandat comme il n'était pas
rééligible il pouvait prendre
effectivement le risque de en quelque
sorte de rétablir les relations
diplomatiques
surtout que c'est un président beaucoup
plus jeune que haydn et qui devait
justifier aussi son prix nobel de la
paix et qui a été effectivement apprécié
dans beaucoup plus ouvert dans l'île
avec une politique en quelque sorte de
sauve pas
vis-à-vis de d2 de cuba mais l'objectif
reste est toujours la même c'est à dire
de charge de changer le régime très
courte majorité
c'était parce que j'aurais été là la
nature du patient de tous les présidents
américains depuis le depuis le xviiie
siècle il nous reste quelques secondes
très courant souvient raul castro avait
lui pris la voie de la privatisation ou
est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
à leur privatisation est un grand mot
disons qu renforcement du secteur privé
vous savez il y avait un certain nombre
d'eux de petits lui tire quelque sorte
autorisé à actions propres des auto
entrepreneurs donc ce ce secteur privé a
été est en train d'être renforcée et un
certain nombre d'initiatives et
notamment pour des entreprises petites
et moyennes entreprises ont été prise
très récemment par le gouvernement
l'ouverture évidemment de l'économie à
des investissements étrangers et la
multiplication le partenariat avec d un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde
pour eux essayer de contrer cet
isolement renforcé par cette pression et
cet embargo nord-américain qui est le
plus long embargo commercial politique
et financier de tous les temps en cas
notre contemporaine merci beaucoup et
stéphane vittoz ski pour votre éclairage
ce matin sur rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes président du conseil
d'orientation de stratégie de lille et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine